[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
so I announced warning I'm suspending my
campaign for president I say this with a
deep sense of gratitude for every single
person who got in this fight
every single person who tried on a new
idea every single person just moved in
their notion of what a president of the
United States should look like I will
not be running for president in 2020 but
I guarantee I will stay in the fight for
the hard-working folks across this
country have gotten the short end of the
stick over and over that's been the
fight of my life well let's take a deep
breath and spend a little time on that
we don't have to
I know one of the hardest parts of this
is all those papers I have all those
little girls not today not today I need
space around this and want to take a
little time to think a little more I've
been I've been spending a lot of time
right now on the question of suspending
and also making sure that this works
it's best we can oh I do I have no
regrets at all it this has been an honor
of a lifetime
ten years ago I was teaching a few
blocks from here and talking about what
was broken in America and ideas for how
to fix it and pretty much nobody wanted
to hear it and I've had a chance to get
out there and talk with millions of
people and you know we have ideas now
that we talk about that we just weren't
talking about even a year ago a two-cent
wealth tax and universe a child care
that could be real we could make it
happen and canceling student loan debt
for 43 million Americans and raising
Social Security payments those are
life-changing um events for people and
we can actually do so I'm delighted to
have been an honor to have had this
chance
you know I was told at the beginning of
this whole undertaking that there are
two lanes a progressive length that
Bernie Sanders is the incumbent for and
a moderate lane that Joe Biden is the
incumbent for and there's no room for
anyone else in this I thought that
wasn't right but evidently I was wrong
as I said I think that I was told when I
first got into this there are two lanes
and I thought it was possible that that
wasn't the case that there was more room
and more route another campaign I am
deeply grateful to the people of
Massachusetts
well back in 2012 they took a chance on
someone who had never run for public
office before they ousted a very popular
incumbent Republican senator to give me
a chance to stand up on a bigger
platform and fight for their families
and I am deeply grateful today they
return me to the Senate and 2018 I'm
deeply grateful for that they're the
reason I'm in this fight and they're the
reason I can I am able to stand here
today
I did
so um it was i stood up voting booth and
I looked down and I saw my name on the
ballot
and I thought wow kiddo you're not no
Coahoma anymore uh that it really was a
moment of thinking about how my mother
and dad if they were still here would
feel about this I had gotten long email
from my nephew and how proud his dad my
brother is and how they were all had
their plans to vote it is this long time
that moment I miss my mom and my dad
gender in this race you know that is the
trap question for everyone if you say
yeah there was sexism in this race
everyone says whiner and if you say no
there was no sexism about a bazillion
women think what planet do you live on I
promise you this
nice to your supporters right now
looking for candidates you're obviously
anybody what let's take a deep breath
and think about this what were you
thinking about what informed this is
laughs you know a big part of it is to
think about all the people who turned
their lives upside down to be part of
this campaign all of the staffers who
moved and worked long hours gave up jobs
to be here took leaves from school to
think about what works for them this
isn't just about me this is a whole lot
of people who were a big part of this
and also our volunteers to try to think
through for all those people who already
have invested so many hours and so much
of their heart and the phone calls and
the door knocks and the coming to the
office and help clean things up and keep
it all going and think about all those
pinkie promises you know so those are
the things I needed to think for him and
how we make all those pieces work at
least as best we can for everyone and
one last time it's about all the people
who are affected by all the issues have
talked about whether they got involved
in my fight for someone else's fight or
even not at all but however we talk
about this there still is a trillion and
a half dollars of student loan debt
outstanding there are still tens of
millions of people across this country
who one one bad medical diagnosis and
they're upside down financially there
are still mamas and daddies all across
this country who can't finish their
education can't take on jobs because
they can't find access to decent
childcare that they can afford
and I had to think a lot about where is
the best place for me to go to keep
fighting those fights because those
problems don't disappear when I stand
here in front of you those problems go
on and my job is to keep fighting and to
fight this smartly and effectively
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]